you're half Asian and you have referred
to your mom I read this in wondering if
you refer to her as a tiger mom while
you were growing up how intense was she
how much of a disciplinarian my mother
is pretty intense there any Asians in
the audience you were probably all hit
because that's what Asians do yeah you
don't hit your children do you know I
don't normally hit their children but
Asian have you been in the South I mean
have you been to Walmart
Asians go to Costco we buy in bulk yeah
so what happened so we'll just my mom
hits a let me hit a lot is kind of just
part of my childhood
very nice childhood so like for example
like when I'd go to sleep at nights here
to room with my sister we'd always talk
and my mom was a guitar mom so she'd sit
right outside our room and listen for us
to if we were talking then if we were
talking she'd come in and be like you
stupid kids shut up I tell you to talk
you have to shut up and she coming to
hit us now when you say hits you you
don't mean to let you mean just like
like slide like a hit oh okay like hit
or grabber yeah kick yeah everything
whatever she could do she would do to us
and so like when we whatever I come home
with a bad grade and I didn't to tell
her I would go into a space that I knew
there was only soft things like the
living room so cuz she would just pick
up anything and throw it like that's
what agents do they just picked up
something with you're planning a
horrible yeah it's really yeah you know
maybe just my Asian family I made myself
feel better all these years and like you
know it's a whole cultural let's say
you're in your room and she hears you
talking she comes in was there anything
that you learned to do to like yes we
did because you have to get smart that's
the good thing about hitting your kids
like eventually they get they get
smarter about it
so we I'm gonna distance myself from
that remark
you've ended up covering ourselves with
comforters and blankets and then put our
sheet on top of us and so we keep
talking so when she came and she hit us
it wouldn't hurt us so one night she she
came in just stupid kids stop talking so
we pulled on our blankets and kept
talking and then we hear come in again
you don't you stupid kids I told you not
to talk you come sit he hit us and then
there's this like really soft thud you
hear and then this look in her eyes and
I remember in the dark those tiger mom
eyes was just like you stupid kid you
tricking me and then she rips it all off
and then beats as hard if you're saying
that her eyes glowed in the dark
worse how does your mom feel about you
she's is she gonna say that she's gonna
hear about this is your mom okay with
this my mom she says no shame she would
say to you like oh it's okay I just kiss
on her you know look she's successful
now I do good job she's never learned to
use the English language she speaks in
an accent and she writes in one - and
she's been here for a very long time and
I just think mom you've been in America
so long lose the accent but it works for
her gets out of speeding tickets people
feel bad for her - oh I'm just a little
Asian lady I'm gonna try that the next
time I get pulled over
I'm just a little asian lady okay we
have a clip here from the newsroom we're
almost out of time because you've been
so entertaining but what can you tell us
about this clip this is a clip with
myself and character Maggie and some
girl put some video of her online and
we're trying to get it off right it's an
embarrassing video of her losing it I've
seen that she's I watch her on that show
she kicks ass how many Twitter followers
do you have I have over 300 I have more
than that I'm gonna give you something
to tweet and I'll retweet it in an
exchange you'll take down the video how
many do you have more than 300 how many
450,000 you do not have 450,000 she does
are you famous she's very well-known and
respected in certain sir what are you
famous for making other people rich
[Applause]